et forcément on est allé également au qg
d'eric zemmour la campagne avait très
bien commencé il était monté très haut
dans les sondages avant de de fer 7 %
hier on a fait un petit tour à son qg
regardez
on allait voir ce qui se passait du côté
d'eric zemmour qui était à la maison de
la mutualité dans un qg qui avait des
airs de fashion week
et certains n'y ont vu que du feu
à l'extérieur on a aussi croisé un mec
qui devrait visiblement changé de
lunettes
et 2 kg appelé à voter pour le candidat
de reconquête mais pas forcément pour
les bonnes raisons tout le monde vote et
eric ses mots sa pêche ue-maroc
d'avion les chiens une fois à
l'intérieur les militants croyait grave
à la victoire je le sens bien je le sens
bien
donc deux ans plus tard
il est petit fournil discours d'eric
zemmour puis changer quelque chose
ils repensent donc à ce mec qui est
sûrement déçus des murs en pierre méric
série
à 20 heures quand les résultats sont
tombés bien entendu tous ses militants
affrontent n'avait pas la même réaction
il y avait des déçus on avait des
comptes en vous allez voir certains sont
passés ont passé la meilleure soirée et
d'autres ont passé leur quart soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah
onze ans